aquí tenemos dos de las derivadas más
útiles en cálculo ya sabemos que la
derivada con respecto a x del seno de x
es el coseno de x y que la derivada con
respecto a x del coseno de x es el menos
seno de x y con estas derivadas de hecho
puedes resolver derivadas más
complicadas pero en esta ocasión vamos a
ir más profundo vamos a demostrar esta
primera derivada no voy a probar la
segunda pero tú puedes hacerlo
simplemente usando la información de
esta primera derivada inténtalo estoy
seguro que esto te hará sentir muy bien
porque ahora podrás asegurar que esta
derivada es cierta y que hay un rigor
matemático detrás de la demostración así
que intentemos demostrar la entonces la
derivada con respecto a x del seno de x
por definición va a ser igual al límite
cuando delta de x tiende a 0
seno de x + delta de x menos seno de x
todo esto entre delta de x esto es
solamente la pendiente de la recta
tangente entre el punto x
x y el punto x + delta de x seno de
equis delta de x así que como podemos
evaluar este límite bueno podemos
reescribir el seno de x + delta de x
usando nuestras fórmulas de sumas de
ángulos es decir usando nuestras
identidades trigonométricas así que esto
va a ser igual al límite cuanto delta de
x tiende a cero de y en lugar de
escribir el seno de x más delta de x
vamos a usar nuestras identidades
trigonométricas y escribir
rosendo de x por el seno de delta de x
coseno de x por el seno de delta de x
más el seno de x por el coste no de
delta de x eso es lo mismo que el seno
de x más delta de x
después de estar este seno de x que
teníamos acá arriba y dividir todo entre
delta de x así que esto se puede
reescribir como el límite cuando delta
de x tiende a cero de y déjame escribir
primero esta parte de rojo coseno de x
por el seno de delta de x entre delta de
x + y ahora voy a poner con color salmón
todo lo demás el seno de x por el coseno
de delta de x menos el seno de x entre
delta de x vamos a ponerlo el seno de x
por coseno de delta de x - el seno de x
todo eso entre delta de x esto lo hice
porque todos se dividen entre delta de x
y recuerda estoy tomando el límite de
toda esta expresión bueno de hecho el
límite de la suma es lo mismo que la
suma de los límites así que esto va a
ser igual a am
el límite cuando delta se extiende a 0 d
y puedo describir esto como coseno de x
por seno de delta de x entre delta de x
más el límite cuando delta de x tiende a
0 de y bueno aquí puedo factorizar un
seno de x cuidado esto es lo mismo que
el seno de x que multiplica al coseno de
delta de x menos 1 entre delta de x y
bueno déjame ver qué puedo hacer con
este límite
lo primero que puedo hacer es bajar un
poco la pantalla para que tengamos más
espacio y bueno en el primer sumando
puede reescribir esto como bueno observa
alcocer no de x no le pasa nada cuando
delta de x tiende a cero entonces lo voy
a sacar del límite y me va a quedar el
coste de x por el límite cuando delta se
extiende a 0 d el seno de delta de x
entre delta tx
y ahora tengo esta otra expresión bueno
lo primero que voy a hacer es cambiar un
poco el coseno de x menos 1 y lo voy a
poner como 1 - coseno de x que
multiplica a menos 1 y luego tengo por
aquí al seno de x x menos 1 es menos
seno de x al cual no le pasa nada cuando
delta de x tiende a cero
entonces lo voy a sacar de igual manera
que hice en el primer sumando y me va a
quedar el menos seno de x que multiplica
al límite cuando delta dx tiende a cero
1 - coseno de delta de equis entre delta
de x ahora en este vídeo no lo voy a
hacer pero en otros vídeos si lo hice
usando el teorema de comparación o del
sándwich demostré que este límite tiende
a 1 esto es igual a 1 y también en otro
vídeo probamos
basándonos en la idea de que este límite
era igual a 1 que este otro límite es de
hecho 0 ahora si nos quedamos con
te encargo que veas los vídeos de cómo
hice las pruebas de esos límites es
decir de estos dos límites porque son
realmente útiles en general en todo el
cálculo y con lo que nos quedaremos es
con bueno coseno de x por uno menos seno
de x por cero lo cual es simplemente
coseno de x y ya está lo hemos logrado
hasta la próxima